the key point that he said is that every
business that is going to grow and be
self-sustaining must have three
superstars you need to have somebody
who's in charge of acquisition you know
if someone is in charge of delivery and
someone who's in charge of operations
and shared services that means one
person gets new clients one person
delivers on promises and the third
person keeps the first two out of jail
by making sure that bills are paid and
payroll happens and legal and i.t and
all the lovely things that come with
running a business that no one ever
thinks about he was like if you have
three superstars then that business can
grow on its own and i think one of the
biggest mistakes that i made for the
vast majority of my early business
career was when i started out in my
career i thought that i just had to
partner with everyone and that wasn't
the right call for me at the time
because i ended up partnering with
people who had the same skill sets as me
because they seemed cool and we liked
the same things but the reality is that
i should have been partnering with
people who had different skill sets so i
might have been the acquisition guy
because that's probably i would say my
my skill set um but i should have
partnered with somebody who was really
good at delivery service product etc and
had somebody who really owned the
operational you know portion of the
business